welcome back with us again is the crew
of Southwest flight 1380 captain Tammy
Joe Schultz first officer Darren Ellis
or and flight attendants Rachel fern
himer Sonique Mallory and Catherine's
and of all team Jon I want to ask you
you talked about the preparation of the
Lord that it you all had had before and
what about the preparation from your
military service it definitely came in
besides the fact just Mike carrier
landings get your heart pumping a little
bit
and and then I taught out-of-control
flight as well and so there was just a
lot of dynamic flight training and then
going into a7s and f-18s in a small
aggressor squadron so when you talk
about out-of-control flight how many
times had you been in a cockpit when
this kind of a thing was going on even
if in training or in previous instances
I've never been in a cockpit where this
kind of thing was going on but I have
been in cockpits where the dynamics of
the flight are not normal and they also
make it hard to even see or read the
instrumentation so that certainly helped
to kind of keep keep my calm when this
sudden explosion happened and we are
moving in a radical way and we're not in
balanced flight so it was was it really
shaking was it yes because I saw an
interview where you said as long as you
have altitude and imagination or ideas
you have a shot what was the word to use
altitude altitude and ideas so what was
the idea Darrin that you had at that
time the plane is vibrating there's a
pitch I don't know what that pitch means
how can you paint the picture what it
was it was a little over 40 degrees of
roll so that's when the plane banks yeah
and it's it's about 10 to 15 degrees
more than a normal turn would be but it
happened very suddenly and there was a
very high level of vibration coming from
the engine so when you if you factor all
that in with the rapid decompression it
was you know my I just have to get the
wings level
the nose up a little bit let the plane
that's all I can do it's what you
trained for yeah and what do you
communicate via intercom to the back of
the plane initially our our job is to
get on oxygen
to take care of ourselves first
communicate with ourselves and once we
take care of the plane and get the first
initial checklist then our job is to
talk to the flight attendants and find
out okay what's goin on back there how
are you doing and you guys say that once
you heard Philadelphia that's all you
heard that was good for you you had knew
where you were going that see that place
to land
yeah honey quite spin like getting back
up in the air I'm just taking my time I
want to make sure that I'm a hundred
percent myself before I can pour out
into the passengers because that's my
job is to be there primarily for their
safety so I'm just taking care of myself
and just before I get in back into the
groove of things you know we saw the
video of most of the passengers using
the oxygen mask wrong and I know as
flight attendants most of the time
passengers are not paying attention are
you thinking now maybe you'll listen to
us because very the instructions we're
not just there to serve you peanuts and
cokes this is very important that you
know exactly what to do when most
passengers did not and we have to give
them grace it's a difficult situation
and no one expects that to happen to
them and and so it's it's difficult -
you're shaking and you're putting on a
mask and you're just trying to get just
a good breath of oxygen in you and so
you know and that was our job - we walk
around and we make sure that everyone
that's putting on their mask right and
getting oxygen and so pay attention yes
okay you're teaching in the job what
happened when you when you landed that
plane I understand you gave every
passenger a hug on the way out but one
of the things is when that plane lanes
if I were the passenger I'd want to get
right off that plane how did how did
they keep everybody calm inside you know
I think one of the unsung heroes is
probably Darren in there
because he made keeping in contact with
the flight attendants his priority I was
flying and talking because initially it
was hard for us to communicate as well
we had a little pilot charade going on
for technology and but we did we just
went ahead and creatively split the
cockpit and I flew in talks while he
took care of all the switch ology
because there's a lot of things going on
with different systems that actually
need to be shut down like the fuel on
that on that wing needed to be that
engine needed to be shut off and things
like that so he took care of switches
checklists but he was always available
when they called so that he could answer
their questions you could give them
information because it's so different
when you're in the back and you don't
see what's happening you have no control
of what's happening and you don't know
what they're doing right I'm thinking
about so he kept them calm they are
people in fought and formed and kept
them calm so when we landed and I turned
over the checklist the finishing of it
to Darren we're there right so meet all
of you you are such incredible mingle
yeah